no one would ever save Wuppertal is
boring and ugly would they the city does
have its charming spots and it has a
long industrial history
it even has a company that leads the
world market in its field but nobody
knows that so this woman aims to change
that December Stephanie Hill Baruch has
been trying to recruit specialists and
managers yes that position is still open
ideally you should apply on our website
Stephanie is currently trying to fill
eleven jobs if you scroll all the way
down you'll find the button apply now we
have to become known beyond our own
region if we're going to remain
successful Wuppertal is not the most
popular place to live
while the people here like it but many
outsiders don't want to move here and
work for a company that makes pliers
that doesn't sound like a
future-oriented industry buck nip ex
offers secure jobs its annual sales have
now topped 100 million euros more than
1,000 people work here the company
doesn't want us filming everything in
their production why let the competition
learn your trade secrets but what's so
special about manufacturing pliers
the personnel department is working to
show how the company is an especially
attractive place to work this is called
employer branding do people fall for
that we're very careful that what we
project outward matches what we do
internally we want people to know we're
not just some boring mid-sized company
but one that has a lot to offer a great
atmosphere flat hierarchies and we
reflect that it's not fake it's fact so
we can do it well and it functions well
to Yen scowl Merton is relatively new to
the plant 37 years old he's head of the
machine engineering division he was
hired to solve problems the product is
very simple it consists of just three
parts two shanks and a rivet but you
wouldn't believe how many steps of work
are involved there aren't any machines
on the market to do one of the work
steps that's the interesting part
developing a new kind of machine that
does exactly what the company needs the
engineer was wooed away from another
company this woman came to clip X with
an unsolicited application Daniella her
house is a native of Wahpeton
now she's international sales manager
for southern Europe
she has to complete a product schooling
course like all of nip X's new employees
we asked her how much this pair of
pliers costs
that's nobuta Farah that's a good
question I've just been here four months
and we have more than 120 different
types of pliers with about ten versions
of each so that's 1200 to 1600 prices I
have to know so not yet but ask me again
later the catalog says it costs 90 euros
what we notice overall is that all the
employees identify with the pliers that
was one of the reasons Torsten haircuts
moved here from effort
he's been director of training since
February for us made in Germany is not
just a label we embody quality and I
like that and I felt it every single day
the short time I've been here
it took the company a year and a half to
find a training director the personnel
office aims to fill vacancies faster in
the future